Richard Deutsch joining us from Toronto
the Sports Illustrated media critic
columnist and Richard thanks for joining
us give me be philosophy about doing it
this way with TNT TBS as opposed to the
last 130 years on CBS dan good to be
with you I feel like I should be calling
you from Smyrna you know Turner has had
the option to do the selection show
based on the contract they signed with
CBS they opted in the past not to do it
they decided to take that option this
year with the philosophy that like you
said people will find it the difference
between something on cable and something
on television on network it's not so
great with the exception of viewership
where it's great and I think Turner just
wants to put its own stamp on this
process that's why you're seeing you
know a 300 person audience come in and
that's why you're seeing as everyone has
talked about these changes where the
plan is to unveil in the first 10
minutes in alphabetical order all the
teams then the matchups are slotted into
the seeds and the brackets the teams
will be grouped by auto bed and at-large
and according to CBS and Turner
they say all of this including and the
unveiling in the brackets will be done
within 45 minutes where I think they're
making a little bit too much of a
mistake is that I understand TBS wants
to put its own you know it's sort of its
own spin on stuff and you can understand
that it's the first time doing this
they're excited they have a lot of smart
people there but and I'm stealing alive
from Dan Walken and I think you've said
this on your show earlier the brackets
are the star of the show I mean it's not
changing this up to sort of come up with
some kind of new unique format to give
us all the teams that are going to be in
the tournament that information in the
end is really kind of irrelevant without
the bracket part of the show so if I was
an executive I would have done with CBS
did last year they listen to their
viewers they decided not to extend this
for an hour plus they got the brackets
out fast and then basically you know
stay with your conviction don't worry
that ESPN is going to be doing this on
their airway
and try to keep people tuned to your
network because you offer really
interesting analysis yeah I agree with
that philosophy here and I understand
that they want to make it theirs and
there are certain things that they're
going to try that in five years they may
not be doing it but I do want to sell
our analysis here our experts here and I
wouldn't be worried about ESPN and I I
would just treat this as how do we do
the best possible show instead of saying
oh my gosh they're gonna all leave us
you know after 32 minutes here and I
think sometimes you can out think
yourself when it comes to these these
shows I think you're absolutely this is
why you should be running Network Stan
you're absolutely right in this case in
this case you're correct I think they're
doing a little bit too much because they
want to separate themselves from CBS and
here's actually the reason and you
mention this at the top a little bit I
have some numbers here that'll sort of
back this up the fact is because it's on
TBS this year the viewership is gonna be
the lowest of all time that's just a
product of network versus cable TBS
having 23 million less homes than CBS I
look at the viewership over the last
token back nine years now
in 2009 CBS s election show drew seven
million viewers big number last year
dropped to four point eight million so
the audience is leaving a lot of that
has to do with of course changing
viewership and people migrating from
cable to just ordinarily world and
everything else so you make the
presumption if I'm TBS that you're gonna
lose viewers anyway just because of the
changing shape of television why make
such a dramatic change why not give the
people at least who have stayed loyal to
this election show what they want and
it's overwhelmingly clear what they want
and they want brackets quickly they want
to see the stuff on the screen so they
could start getting in their minds who
they're gonna pick for their office
pools and that's where I think some of
this blowback
I think Turner like you said sort of
out-thought itself a little bit there
there's no need to change you know the
wheel this dramatic you could put some
nice touches on the wheel but you know
you don't have to take a motorcycle
where you were driving a Ford
for a while Richard Dyke Sports
Illustrated media writer let me get a
Peyton Manning question in there for you
Richard before I let you go is he in
play for an analyst job does he does he
consider himself in play first of all I
think ESPN Dan would give Tate in the
building perhaps they'd even give him
the new presidency if he would take this
job I think they really would like I
think he's more in play this year and
then he ever has before he he has a very
big agent the Montague group that's
doing his broadcasting I'm sure Dan
you've heard of that so it's a little
inside baseball but sandy Montague the
guy is represented very famous people
from Mike Tirico to Bob Costas et cetera
and so I think you know I think Satan is
from what I understand I think he's
considering the possibility of
broadcasting more than he ever has
before but from everything I understand
he hasn't given any indication that he's
definitely going to do it I think if he
did decide to do it this year
I think the Fox job would be far more
appealing to him than the Monday Night
Football job giving travel giving it's
on a network and given that Fox I think
would be very very good in terms of
giving Payton whatever he wanted
regarding schedule I mean Payton
probably could leave that game I would
imagine Fox so you know they might even
have a [ __ ] plane for him Dan literally
outside of the stadium and flying back
wherever he needs to be so if he ends up
doing it I think Fox would be the only
place he would do it this year but I
think I would still bet the under he's
always and you've had you've interviewed
him anytime
he's always spoken about something
larger than broadcasting like ownership
or management so I'd be surprised if he
actually do you think Tony Romo and his
impact had any or has any impact on
Payton's future doing this I do I yeah
because I think I think Payton who's a
very bright guy saw Tony have such
immense success both critically and with
viewers in his first year and Tony was
really a product of preparation when it
came to broadcasting and CBS say their
credit had a great plan they basically
did a camp with Tony where months before
he was ever going to go on air CBS
people including Jim Nantz came down to
Dallas
Tony essentially had a broadcasting
trainer which was pretty fast
to work with em on just the mechanics of
the profession so yeah I think Peyton
saw that and if nothing else that you
know what there's a guy who did not have
any broadcasting reps like me who came
in he's arguably either the best or the
second best NFL analyst working today
depending on how you feel about Cris
Collinsworth so I think that probably
did give Peyton at least a little bit of
maybe some rethought in terms of you
know I could come in and do this at a
high level the way Tony did I'm a big
Tony Romo fan book I think he was
tremendous and I appreciate people who
take analysis to the second level just
to sort of teach me things about the
game and I thought he was a revelation
this year Richard thank you for the
insights we appreciate it safe travels
back from Toronto thanks that's Richard
Deutsch sports illustrated media critic
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]